welcome everyone to the data science
hangout
and this is if this is your first time
joining this is an open space for the
whole data science community to connect
and chat about data science leadership
what's going on in the world of data
science
and really just questions that you're
all facing as well so we really want to
create a space where everybody can
participate and we can hear from
everyone
so there are multiple ways that you can
jump in the conversation and ask
questions
you could jump in live
you can put questions in the chat
and then we also have a slido link where
you could ask anonymous questions too
so the session will be recorded and
shared up to youtube
so you can always use the anonymous way
of asking questions if you prefer to not
be part of that
also if you want to ask a question in
the chat and
maybe you're in a
crowded loud room and you don't you want
me to read that out you can just put a
little star at the end of it as well and
i'll know to read that for you
but thank you all so much for for
joining i'm so excited to be joined by
my co-host for today who you may have
seen as an attendee on a few of the past
sessions aaliyah wacko
aaliyah is a
epidemiology team lead at the texas
department of state health services
analyst i'd love to just kind of turn
over to you first to just introduce
yourself and share a bit about some of
the work that you do on your team if
that's okay
yeah sure so thank you so much rachel um
so like rachel said i am an
epidemiologist
the majority of my experience has been
in government so i've worked at the
federal level
i had an opportunity to work with the
centers for disease control and
prevention
and i have also worked at the state
level um and i'm actually excited
because i'm currently transitioning into
a new role um from an epidemiologist a
epidemiology team lead
with the texas department of state
health services to an analytics manager
um position which is really exciting um
so right now
um uh the position that i am in is that
we are developing a center of public
health informatics um and as an
analytics manager i have the opportunity
to work with um
our stakeholders that are in the
community but also within the agency
and to really develop our um
skills and our knowledge around how do
we um leverage working with data and
public health um to really combat a lot
of public health issues within the state
um and then also building the a
community
um that really is comfortable with
working with data um so that includes
managing analyzing and most importantly
communicating data um so right now my
team um
is tasked with building out not only our
analytic abilities but also um
developing the workforce um that we
collaborate really closely um so
i think that's really been exciting for
me just trying to figure out strategies
um to get people who
um maybe they aren't really uh they
don't really have those hard technical
skills in working with data but they do
use data for like their strategic
planning um to make decisions um so
really just empowering them
um to leverage data in their everyday
work
that's awesome and i i know one of the
things you said that you're most
passionate about is being able to bring
data science to everybody yeah and i'm
just curious what are some of the
strategies that you're taking to do that
yeah so um
most recently i really got on board with
um
data literacy so if everyone isn't
familiar with data literacy it's the
ability to um read work with analyze
communicate and argue with data um so it
is i would say it's like a trending
topic right now
um and
data literacy in my mind is really just
meant for everyone it's not just meant
for you know the epidemiologists like
myself who have a strong research
background or data analyst but it's also
meant for
business leaders and even
um you know nurses consultants um
medical doctors again i work in public
health so a lot of my references might
be health related um but that it is it
is for everyone that everyone um can
utilize these skills and benefit from um
just knowing some foundations around
how do i interpret um
you know results that are presented in
some literature or even presented and
news articles um and and i would say
that um right now a couple of a couple
of the strategies that we are
implementing um first is just getting an
understanding of where um other teams
are and their abilities and and and in
their knowledge um so we are data folks
so
we're surveying um we're putting out
assessments giving people the
opportunity um to let us know what kind
of
programs that they have experience with
what is their level of comfort working
in some of these programs which includes
sas
excel tableau
rstudio
and then also are they open to learning
other programs um so we are also um
with the center of public health
informatics we're expanding um to
really centralize all of the data that
we use and all the technologies that we
used um and um moving forward to become
a bit more data science
centered um so we're really trying to
make a push from those that have
traditionally worked in sas to start
using r in our studio
those that traditionally you know work
in excel and have those foundations and
maybe you know they are able to create
charts in excel to start moving towards
um using tableau
um so things like that um so as far as
just getting a lay of the lamp um doing
assessments and surveys
we'll also be creating some metrics for
us
to be able to monitor and track over
time
to see how
you know from baseline
to to whenever we want to survey it
again to actually see if people are kind
of making some progress um towards
understanding these technologies um and
we also are um
um we are creating um communities around
sharing knowledge so we will be
developing webinars um
that will host maybe monthly
um quarterly
where people can come join we'll have
speakers that are possibly talking about
um what they're doing and are or some
visualizations that they're doing in
tableau um and then also
[Music]
holding office hours um
with some of our experts on our team we
do have like tableau coordinators um so
just making sure that they're available
for people that are interested and if
they are working on a project that they
can receive some guidance and some
consultation on a project that they're
working with
and then also we were able to
procure um
agency-wide licenses for for data camp
um so data camp is a platform like
coursera um but we we do have um the
enterprise access so we have access
to all the courses that include
um you know how to develop dashboards um
courses on machine learning
and predictive analytics
and also some courses around theories um
and just um building that knowledge of
how to work with data um so yeah so
those are like a couple of things that
that we're working on now
nice and so i i know you said you're
just launching some of those webinars
too how are you going about like
sharing it with everybody and launching
the program
so that's a really good question i will
say that i'm happy that we're in a
position to
where we plan on it being iterative
so really just you know let's see what
works if it doesn't work let's revisit
and try something else um so right now
um we have identified um
a team of i believe that they are
um disease
a disease prevention team
and they're actually interested in
learning a bit more about tableau and
how to do some dashboard building so we
do have a tableau coordinator who will
start he'll he'll actually develop a
webinar um based off of some of the
skills that they already have so he can
get an idea of where they are um and
he'll he'll create a webinar for them
and i would say that it'll be like a
pilot
just to see how it goes with them and if
it goes well
then this is something that will
hopefully expand to other teams
and ways that we'll communicate um
will
of course be through email but we also
have
um weekly meetings that we are able to
um communicate with teams that are it's
like all hands on deck um meeting weekly
so we're able to communicate with other
people that aren't
aren't on our teams um so this would
just be another way for us to to put it
out there let them know um what what
what we're doing
um how they can join us um and just
letting them know our vision and how we
do plan on um really supporting them and
this this expansion of trying to build
up our data knowledge and our skills
that's great i i see there's a lot of
questions coming through in the chat so
i'd love to bring a few other people
into the conversation too except i see
you just asked something around the the
workshops too
yeah hi elia my name's sep um thanks for
taking the time to share your story with
us um my my curiosity was around like
these workshops
and whether they're going to be
mandatory or is there like a broader
program to kind of onboard people if you
don't mind talking about that in great
yeah i think that's a great question and
um as far as it being mandatory since we
are in public health and covet is really
a huge it's still a huge thing that we
are really sensitive um on knowing that
a lot of our workforce is still focused
on oncobid um
so a lot of their time and capacity is
really going towards
um
monitoring kovitt and just getting it
under wraps within the state so i think
we're sensitive on not wanting to make
it something mandatory um but
the more that we
um you know get this this pandemic
behind us um
then i think that they will be some
workshops that will be mandatory for for
some teams but um
just just really just voluntary um and
if you do have the time to come and join
us if you have the capacity but just be
insensitive that we we are still in a
pandemic and a lot of our workforce um
are working towards those efforts
that's great and hopefully if you get
only a few people then they can help
evangelize and move on from that exactly
that's that's yeah that's a great hope
thank you
frank i see you asked a question earlier
as well if you want to jump in
i appreciate it rachel um
aaliyah thanks thanks like so said for
your time and sharing your experience it
seems like the your initial few minutes
just got a lot of activity and got
people's minds thinking um
where my mind went was as you start to
build out these skills and these ways of
thinking around the company there's
going to end up being pockets of
information and then you'll ultimately
have conflicts and you'll have teams and
team members saying
well people aren't aligned and we have
people working on the same stuff and i
think in a giant company that is
inevitable
uh i've handled that one way in my own
experience but i'm curious right is that
something that you think about and
worries you or are you like now that's
way too far down the road kind of
where's your your mind on that
yeah so with the development of um our
new center
um it actually was to resolve a lot of
those problems that we were seeing
within the agency because we have um
yeah public health organization it's
very interesting um you know we're all
epidemiologists but everyone has their
different topic of focus um everyone has
um you know their their different
expertise so because of that there are
different offices and teams and what we
were seeing what that there was a very
much um a um
just like an array of
um
like an array and a duplication of
things that were already being done so
this center was actually one of those
things that was brought up in order to
help us centralize across the agency
and thinking about how can we one
communicate more between each other
um and how can our center be that
liaison so we do have an understanding
of what every team is working on and
also so that they can rely on us um to
be kind of this decentralized
um
resource for them
um so i i think for us because we are a
new center um that a lot of it is just
going to be um like learning the
landscape um and then also
um
sharing back out so others know what
other teams are doing
um so
i think right now it's just going to be
a lot of communication and a lot of
standing up um
of these technologies and getting
everyone on board um so i think this is
where the heaviest lift is going to be
but
um i'm excited to even just you know
start to communicate and sharing that
knowledge but i think it's mostly going
to be um how do we just communicate more
and collaborate more so we know what
everyone is doing
is that mostly email and slack
so right now it's i mean right so right
now it is um mostly email and then also
um leveraging these um weekly meetings
that we hold um and these weekly
meetings um include our health
commissioner so he's our health
commissioner for the state it also
includes
our
central office
and then we have another level which is
considered the
district level so those are each local
health district so everyone has a
representative that is on this call and
everyone has the opportunity to share
what they're doing um they have the
floor to discuss anything that they need
um so just thinking of an example um
someone did someone um showcased an
analysis that they did
regarding um
um
cova cases in schools um and then just
sharing that knowledge um and giving
everyone the floor so i i would say
right now it's it's email
um and it is these these like weekly
meetings that we've been having
yeah
thank you
thank you kelly i see you also work in
local government and had a great
question
would you want to can i jump in and add
some context there too
uh sure can you hear me okay yes i can
yeah so i work for a large local public
health department and one of the things
that
i think would really help us in terms of
the pandemic response would be tracking
patients kind of across all of our
different data systems so
looking at our disease reporting
database and linking that with the
immunization registry to see if cases
have been vaccinated or not and then
linking that with syndromic data to see
who's been hospitalized so we can look
at breakthrough case rates
but
in envisioning you know there's the
technical challenges of linking these
systems but then there's kind of the
ethical challenges
and the these data systems
have different data use agreements they
contain
more information than you would expect
about a given person and so when you
start linking them
people who weren't originally intended
to see the data now have access and so
we're having kind of a lot of back and
forth about how do we do this
responsibly
can we even do it um and i'm just kind
of curious to hear how those
conversations are operating at other
health departments
yeah so i can speak on um specifically
in texas um so that was a
huge um
barrier for us um where like you said
kelly that um
because of data use agreements that you
know we couldn't access you know we
couldn't access a certain agency or
offices data but we were able to access
other um
like other offices data and to be honest
i
i
kind of feel like that it should be at a
higher level i don't know who needs to
mandate this that there should be easier
data sharing
um but
i've definitely been in that same
position where we were interested in
doing specific specific analyses but
because of
um you know the people that we're
working with that we just could not
access that data um so it does make our
job like really difficult um when you
know that the data is here
um you know that it's
not accessible but you know that it's
there you know that it exists but you
know we can't get the agreements in so
sometimes we have to go to legal
um we have to go to lawyers um to really
build a case on um you know how are we
going to use this and why do we need it
so i've definitely been in that same
position kelly but
i i
i don't know what the the solution is
thanks that's really helpful
it's at least we know we're all in it
together yeah absolutely
absolutely and then i will say in
my current position because we work with
aggregate aggregate data so we're not
looking at individual
patient level data so once it gets to us
it's all at the state level
thank you um thinking more about like
getting other like teams involved and
like pushing this up to to leadership
too i see zach you asked a great
question earlier as well
and mentioned like ilya you've done a
great job it seems like getting
resources for training people as well um
zach would you want to jump in and add
any context to your question
yeah so uh
i
uh at the moment so i've learned all
this so i just talked about a bit about
my background i've learned this all in
my spare time
and at the moment we're trying to get
other people to learn their stuff and of
course therefore they've gone these like
data cam course and etc are really good
but it's then about
with uh personality that's head of
developing
uh career development i can't remember
what their official title is but that
sort of thing uh developing skills just
generally
and then it's just about how
that person then going up and up until
you get the right senior stakeholder i
was wondering how you achieved that
because you seem to have got a lot of
backing not only with the data camp but
also the workshops
and yeah seems
you've done really well at that i was
just wondering how we achieved that and
what
sort of steps
us or we could generally follow see if
it works for us
so i would actually have to give kudos
to my director
who had put in the work um before i
started this position
and he's been with the agency for a lot
of years and a lot of
different positions
and he's been in a lot of leadership
positions so i i feel like that it could
have a lot to do with
him just having built those partnerships
people know him in the agency they
listen to him they trust his his vision
and they trust his judgment um so
i'm fortunate enough that he also trusts
me and
and to um and with thinking about what
kind of strategies that i'm interested
in implementing and he'll be supportive
of that but i will definitely say that
he has done
all of the leg work um as far as
procuring these contracts with data camp
with our studio with google cloud
he is really envisioning um getting this
um this center to a more data science um
centric center and i would say it's all
because of him um so i'm really just
grateful and appreciative that i can
actually lean on him for for some
guidance um
but i i have
it was not me that's all i'm saying
it sounds like you definitely had a big
part of it though
um
hugh i i do see you
asked earlier about transitioning from
sas to r and i know this is something
that you're doing at your organization
too i believe you if you want to jump in
and ask that question
yeah absolutely hey my name's hugh um
i'm a management analyst with the
federal government
and i was kind of curious if you had any
advice let me firstly i really like
y'all's strategy of like multiple
avenues for increasing data literacy
that's something um that we've struggled
with as well um
but
i want to know if you had any advice you
mention converting uh trying to get
people to learn r if they're comfortable
with sas
and that's an area where we've struggled
with and to be honest i haven't really
made a lot of headway i was wondering if
you had any uh advice or strategies for
success there
yep so i think um
i think that we will be in the same boat
because i think when it comes to
um you know sas users
um they just get kind of comfortable and
the language that that they know um but
one of the things that we do um plan on
doing um is one since we did do that
assessment we do know that there is um
an opening an openness to learning um r
so that's good so that's a good first
step
um and then also just providing those
resources for them to do it so we are
fortunate that we do have these data
camp licenses um
um so um so it's available for them
um however they want to learn it
self-paced um but then also i think what
we will do is um
probably just showcase the abilities the
capabilities that our can do
um and then um from there just kind of
showing them how how easy it is
um to do um knowledge sharing and to
work across teams um so i think for us
it's going to just be providing examples
to them
and how
we hope that it can make their jobs
better
i think once they they can see that
benefit that they'll be a bit
more on board
and then um
i think the more that we push are
um
because even for us as far as like
supporting guidance we
we won't support guidance with sas so
it's like if you're coming to us for
help
we'll
provide support using our tableau
and we're trying to move away from power
power bi so you know we're not going to
be
we're not going to be providing that
that guidance in that way um so i don't
know
we'll see how that goes um
but but yeah i don't i hope that helps
that does thank you
yeah it's nice to hear that the
similar struggles i figured
you know we'd show them the pipe
operator and they'd stampede to r but
that kind of hasn't been the case
[Laughter]
right
thank you thank you thank you
millie i'd love to have you ask your
question too if i can pass the mic over
to you
yeah hello yeah i was curious like what
success looks like for your i guess
mission of data reality at the agency
because it sounds like you know teams
have their
set ways of like working that seems to
like work fine for them and what they've
always been doing
um and i'm wondering what you envision
like saying like okay we've met the
mission of having people
you know be data illiterate and
data science forward and what that looks
like to you
yeah i think that's a good question
um i think for me what that looks like
um you know besides us doing our
assessments um is even in um
i would say like conversation
um and
how well-versed when we speak with each
other are we
incorporating data into the decisions
that we're making so if you know if
we're on a planning meeting um for me
what that would sound like is that we
are
um you know just providing evidence of
why we want to do something you know
based off of you know such and such
analysis like this is what we saw so we
think that this is a good idea so i
think when i just hear of data being
incorporated more in conversations
especially around making decisions and
strategic planning that that's when i
believe that
we've got to a good point
great thank you
alia a question that
i'd love to just talk a little bit about
is i know you mentioned you're moving
into this new role so congratulations
but also for people on the call who are
starting to take that step towards the
new role
or wanting to move up into leadership
how did you go about that or what tips
would you have for people
that is a good question um so
i would say that my transition
to leadership
um
what was first just um expressing that
interest to my management to my
immediate supervisor of letting her know
that hey this is where i want to be in
the next you know two years i'm letting
her know that in the next two years i
would like to be in a leadership
position
um and then based off of that um
going back and forth with her about well
what does a leader look like in her eyes
um and what kind of qualities would this
person have
and then um just kind of creating some
um responsibilities on myself um to get
me in that in that position
um and then um
just taking on the leadership role still
just seeking guidance
i think that it is
something that i'm still getting used to
it still takes practice
but then also
um knowing when to ask questions um and
then you know finding maybe like a
mentor who i i trust um who's also in a
leadership position
um and i think that they could just give
me some great insight they understand
where i'm coming from um so i would say
just just knowing that that was
something that i was interested in like
in the next few years expressing that to
to my manager my leadership
um and then just creating that that road
map
um but i think the first thing is just
letting them know what i wanted
so she was well aware
definitely it's really helpful
patrick i see you had asked a question
earlier around like
the amount of time spent working with
hands-on or hands-on with data as
opposed to managing organizing leading
and
patrick would you want to introduce
yourself or add context to that question
sure thank you rachel and the question
you just asked is really sort of the the
overarching question right that's that's
the bigger question um so i appreciate
that that was a perfect perfect lead
into this um hi elia thank you very much
for your time today i appreciate this
and it's been it's been helpful already
um
i'm patrick tenon i'm with the meadows
institute and we're a health policy
institute in texas um so we we talk to
hhs from time to time and we'll probably
cross paths at some time it sounds like
i'm the director of evaluation and
analytics and right now i'm sort of
making this transition that rachel was
just talking about where uh the data is
uh being pried out of my hands
so to speak uh and i'm going more
towards management and overseeing our
transition to a secure cloud environment
and stuff like that where it's i spend
less time in our studio than i used to
and um maybe would like to i'm still
sort of
determining uh how happy a transition
this is um but so i'm just wondering if
you can talk a little bit about that for
your current role your upcoming role um
how you've how you've thought about uh
what is the right amount of time for you
to sort of be directly in touch with the
data versus overseeing others who are
yeah so that's actually a really good
question because i definitely started
seeing that i am working less
you know one-on-one with the data i'm
more so providing guidance around
analytics you know as like a subject
matter expert i'm just providing
guidance um i'm making sure that it
makes sense for us to do something you
know this way or that way um but then
really just letting my team
um you know do do like the hard um
number crunching um doing the
visualizations
and then you know just providing
guidance around that so i would say that
a lot of the time that i spend with data
now is like reviewing
um and you know taking a look at
something providing feedback
and then i i and then i would say like
talking a lot i feel like now more than
ever i'm just you know talking with
somebody i'm on a meeting um
collaborating with stakeholders
gathering requirements
um
you know getting an idea of what they're
envisioning
um so for me i definitely
um
plan on taking advantage of the data
camp that the data camp license that i
have
just to keep just to keep me fresh
um but it is
definitely yeah i would say that that my
interaction with data is you know
reviewing providing feedback providing
guidance to my team and i will say that
i do also enjoy like advising and
teaching um and providing guidance so i
i have enjoyed that aspect especially
when it comes to
um
you know newer people maybe they're just
starting their career so i think it's
like a really awesome opportunity to to
just think about how i can help them
move along and get them to where they
want to be
um yeah so i think
i will say that it is a huge transition
but i am enjoying it because i think
looking ahead that i would like to be
more in a position where i am providing
guidance where i'm where i am teaching
um i'm also interested in like teaching
data literacy and you know teaching how
to build the dashboard so i think i'm in
the right place and i'm i'm definitely
going where i want to be so yeah
thank you so much that was helpful and
i'll second that piece on on teaching
it's it's been really fun and actually
something i found is that i i think i'm
exploring more broadly now about uh
potential applications and use cases and
things because it's not it's not
specific to one problem or project i i
don't need to solve this i need to find
out sort of what are the things that are
available to us and how can we best
utilize them and then and then putting
those sort of down down the chain um so
i i agree that the teaching piece has
been really helpful for me too and i'm
glad to hear you're enjoying the
transition
and i'll i'll second that as well that a
part of this job also is just figuring
out what is best you know for the agency
so that includes technologies that
includes piloting um civis analytics and
you know just you know how can we
utilize this is this going to be
beneficial for us will people actually
use it so it also is a part of that
decision making and yeah
so kudos yes awesome thanks so much
yep
thanks patrick i think this conversation
around like moving into leadership and
maybe sometimes having to step away from
writing code yourself is really helpful
because i know a lot of people are are
running into that and maybe not
as happy with sometimes how that turns
out
um but matthew i see you asked a great
question about this as well could i have
you ask that one next
sure and pardon my delay coming off mute
and things like that um thank you uh
yeah continuing on it maybe i'd instead
of asking my question i have an analogy
and that's the analogy of
think about a used car lot right and
you've got your sales people in your
management do you promote your best
salesman to lot manager are those
comparable skills sure they know the
product and so i've thought about that
often i've been i'm in uh the education
industry and seeing uh pathways where
you take your good technical people and
in fact i left an organization because
they said well we're gonna promote you
and give you more management experience
and i said well but i i have a phd
non-mba and
i'm not denigrating anything but you
know the recognition of there are
technical pathways and you want to give
some progression and not afford growth
for people who are technically oriented
and then there's
management leadership which is the
traditional sense and how do we think
about that
are those separate paths am i making it
up is there an opportunity and how do we
you know how do we support that idea
i
i like and i'm i'm also open to opening
the floor to hear other leaders and
their take on this but i definitely
agree with
it being you know two-packed because
someone that you know is highly skilled
and you know they produce great
analytics doesn't mean that they'll make
a great manager um but i also think that
there's a difference between you know
you know managing people and managing
projects um so i think that's that's a
that's a really good question um
and i
i it's something for me to think about i
think you know the more that i go down
um
down my my line here
yeah yeah
i think that's a great question as well
i'd love to open it up to everyone as
well because i mean i've thought about
this myself too like what if you don't
want to manage people how do you move
forward
right
and if you're leading those technical
people like how do you say okay there's
no pat like how do you avoid saying
there's no path for forward for you
because you don't want to manage people
i'm i'll be honest right i am actually
in a leadership position and so this is
something i think about just just about
every day i've got great technical
people and i've got great you know
leaders that that i work with but you
know acknowledging people's strengths
when
businesses especially outside of say
software development you know do a
better job of rewarding people
management versus technical leadership
maybe what is there something we can
borrow for anybody that's in software
development on that side you know i've
seen like tech leads in software
development is there an analogy here
where we reward that kind of expertise
and you're managing the technical
thought leadership and how can we borrow
that beg borrow and steal that
yeah
i see a few people have unmuted so i
think they maybe want to add some
thoughts here too so brian do you want
to jump in yeah so we actually we
actually did that when i was at uh
hanover insurance
so we had um
junior associate
data scientist and he had all the way up
to lead data scientists
um
the more senior you got the more people
he managed he also did project but then
we created a fork
and the fork became
um like principal data scientists and a
few other levels up that were that were
beginning to parallel
the management side which would have
been like avp in various positions like
that
um the responsibilities were very
different though and so for your
technical people
it was
you had to do white papers and a lot of
other research technical oriented stuff
to get down that pathway um and it does
open the door to it but um
and it's available so you can't separate
that
it's fairly common in the insurance
industry with actuaries
just because you're a great actuary
doesn't make you a great leader
um and so in order to prevent the churn
in that you have to create positions
where people can do
and use their technical skills
and still kind of progress along the way
and so that was our way around in the
data science world um we we created all
the pathways
we were young enough team so no one
really got to the point of
um approaching that first technical role
but it was open i mean we had it in the
uh
got to bless with the businesses and hr
and everybody else so it was there
and that's your way around it but you're
gonna have to
work with leadership and hr to establish
those pathways
and brian in that example that like more
technical person did they go off to
i guess being like
like the lead of a project
and they just weren't you know managing
like they didn't have people under them
but they were considered like
leads and like
smes specifically yeah so there's a
couple things so you generally you will
probably manage
multiple projects on your own
um and or you may already may be on a
team with it um
but you but kind of like the research
where you're gonna have to publish
something uh and that was those
requirements you know whether it or you
know speak at conferences or something
like that you have to
fulfill this technical
role
um
and so that's what we put it as is
you know whether it was speaking at
conferences or doing white papers or
other stuff that projected
you and the company uh and and now so
that was and so the nice thing about
that it's a pretty easy
it's a pretty transparent requirement
um
you know because we know whether you've
spoken at a conference or you've been
invited to speak or you've
applied um and all these other things so
from that standpoint it's not very
subjective goal um and so i think it
cleanly you know
fits with those type of positions
there's no
you know did you achieve
happiness and also that kind of thing is
did you actually apply for these um
speaking positions did you do it did you
publish papers
and you know
some of it was actually teaching the
team too um and again very measurable
how many
sessions could we we held a session
every month
um
for the whole team it's you know
multiple people presented it was it was
a good couple hours worth um
and you know how often did you get up in
front and present late you know new
stuff so
uh it's all along that line of
projecting and communicating your
knowledge and skills to
other people
brian if i could piggyback off of some
what you're saying uh i'll just do a
quick introduction myself i haven't been
here in a while
i work
in technically i sit within hr i am uh
in a workplace
behavioral scientist role of g
healthcare um and so i spent a lot of
time working on helping people with
developing
career pipelines a lot of the analytics
that we use to help do that stuff
and i think i actually think the
response you gave is great there's a lot
of fantastic suggestions in there i
think uh the other reflection question
you need to consider is sort of where
some of those value-add behaviors are
useful depending on the maturity of your
organization
um because i've also heard the
perspective from someone where some of
those things are not available or
they're not justifying that person's
salary i've seen some fantastic leaders
who leaders who've done a great job of
saying look
this is at this organization's current
standpoint in time
having that blunt conversation of these
are some of the limits i currently see
for you as an employee here at this
organization and a lot of great leaders
i've seen do
do a good job of recognizing that some
people can only go so far in certain
organizations and will try to help that
person move on somewhere else and sort
of by creating a great reputation as a
manager it helps them backfill that role
eventually because that person might
have a recommendation in fact my role
was a backfill from someone else who met
and knew that my manager that i have now
is a great manager so
there are those people end up being in
service to you as long as you're in
service to their career development as
well so i think i think both of those
things have to be considered in in
tandem how far can someone reasonably go
with business context and
you know if there is a lot of room for
themselves to develop i think a lot of
brian's suggestions were really useful
thank you and
rahul i see you had your hand raised as
well that's also
a great way for me to know if people
want to jump in too so we can use those
as well
thanks um
hi i haven't been here in a while either
so uh hi i'm robert welcome back
everybody thank you for coming back
it got busy there for a while and it
sort of dropped off but i'm happy to be
here um
uh so i work uh
now in a finance group i used to be on
the engineering side as a data scientist
and
um
i work at apple and the way things are
done here is that
two separate tracks it's very much in
line with what brian sort of said as
well we have this individual contributor
track and then a managerial track and
they both have progressions and they're
completely separate
right so i've been in a more traditional
manufacturing company for you know in my
previous career and that was the more
traditional you know you become the ic
then the natural progression is you
become a manager for a small team and so
on and so forth and that surprised me
when i
came here is this completely different
so if i have to grow i'm offered like
right now i'm an individual contributor
and i can keep going so i work with ics
who've been here for 15 years at apple
right or 20 years and they're just ics
and the expectation as you keep growing
is you work on more complex stuff
and
you bring innovation to the company and
you're able to influence influencing
other teams
right who are not part of your control
is a big part of it right can you make
big decisions
and can you do a big innovation at apple
by influencing a whole bunch of other
things using your technical expertise
using your personal connections right
and that's your role as you grow in that
individual contributor ladder and if you
want to become a manager then you can
and then the role is really to enable
your ics so the managers are expected to
make sure they're working on the right
projects that we have the right
resources doing you know project
management and resource allocation
making sure people are happy and all of
the all of the managerial piece
and they have to their primary purposes
are my ics happy do they have what they
need to get
the job done and then get out of the way
right and let the ics do the work
uh so
the way we have these discussions every
year is
my manager for example you know he's
asking me all the time okay you know
what do you want to do next
and it's you know you can sort of choose
either path but the paths are completely
different right you can be you know i i
and i feel uh
the way they even motivate you to even
stay attached is a half diet path for ic
and give enough compensation right you
know a lot of times folks end up moving
to managerial because there's not enough
compensation on the ic path right and
it's like yeah i love what i'm doing but
and that happened to me at my previous
companies like i was forced to become a
manager because i hit that glass ceiling
it's like i could be here another 15
years and i'm not going to earn any more
and all of that kind of thing it becomes
real right i want to do what i'm doing
but i also have to earn more money
at least apples they've taken that away
they're like you can stay in ic and we
keep paying you more as long as you do
bigger things you don't have to manage
people
and i i like it so i feel there's less
pressure for me to like move to
management just because i've been here
10 years or something like that right
that's a sort of a bad motivator for me
yeah
that's really helpful perspective reveal
and thank you all for for jumping in on
this conversation too
i um i do to kind of change the track a
little bit i see rachel peters you asked
a great question
and i'll read it aloud because i know
you have some crazy dogs running around
you said
but um
rachel asked i'd like to hear how people
are questioned to aaliyah i'd like to
hear how people handle the tendency for
business partners to put you in the
technical box like make me this
versus being involved in the ideas
process etc
that's a good question wait so the
question is
can you repeat it rachel i'm sorry yeah
yeah definitely so rachel asked i'd like
to hear how people handle the tendency
for business partners to put you in the
technical box
of
hey make me this
versus being involved in the ideas or
the process
yeah so i think um
with us
um
it again kind of goes back to like
the communication and actually working
with leaders leaders so like across the
agency
um
so that they can actually understand
what we are capable of doing why we're
here
um and then again because this center is
new we were built up for a specific
purpose and that one of those main
purposes was to like centralize um our
agency
um so everyone can get on the same page
so we're not duplicating efforts we're
not duplicating work um so i think that
um it definitely um
i think i think that it really takes
place at the leadership um positions to
where our leaders are communicating um
with one another um they are building up
that that rapport
um and then also
um
that it's really kind of this
i don't want to say compromise but it is
this understanding that we should be
collaborating i mean i will say that in
public health that it is supposed to be
like super collaborative in order to
actually make a difference and like to
get things done
um so i i think that um there's actually
an initiative that the cdc
um just put out and it's called like
public health 3.0 um but it actually
does focus on collaboration um so there
is like this huge effort that we do
collaborate more
um so i think that we kind of are on the
same page and we do value that but it
kind of i believe that it will start at
leadership um to create those
relationships so then it can like
trickle down to the rest of us and
they're leading by example that we are
collaborating and that's what we should
be doing
thank you can i jump in and make a cut
make a
further comment on that
sure go ahead ron
okay so i'm ron sokolov i am uh
i'm the chief of informatics here in
veterans administration centered out in
nashville
um
we run into
almost an identical situation where it's
here build i need more granular detail
as is the common order you know it's
like
um you know here's here's a an excel
spreadsheet i need granular detail
it's like and i've learned not to just
roll my eyes but rather what i finally
did was
we don't start a project without a
clearly defined scope of work
where we
sit down with
the person who made the very vague
request
and we force we don't like force them
force them but we we talk them through
not just what
what is their goal okay that's your goal
we slowly work backwards to your data
points and how do you want to look at it
you want and by really involving them in
the process
we've really had great success in
getting them to understand
what we do
and by incorporating the data analytics
into that discussion and showing them
what their various options are
it's gone a long way to get us involved
in these sorts of discussions
earlier on
perhaps not at the beginning but much
earlier on in a much better
more refined
request for uh
for a product
thank you
yeah i think that's a great example
ronald thank you
yeah thank you thanks so much ronald
javier i i see you have your hand raised
as well if you want to jump in and ask
your question
yeah thanks actually it's just to
piggyback off of what ron said um
ronald
ronald
sorry i think he said ron i know iran
but i answer almost anything
okay yeah so just to piggyback off of
ron's comments and and actually
sort of
you know i had worked with a lot of
actuaries
um
over my career and so
i've seen this sort of dynamic where
if we're building out
shiny apps or dashboards for
a less technical audience
that will also be used by a technical
group
that
there's like less trust
in the app as a whole if the technical
users don't have the ability to
extract the data or see how it is you
calculated all these metrics so
what we started doing for all of our
shiny apps was to have a
you know like a download
excel button pretty much right like an
action button you download the file if
you use the open xlsx package
or there's a few of these um
i i prefer open xlsx but
you can create like
very
pre-styled
uh dashboards i'm sorry excel files as
downloads and that
you know that seemed to sort of give our
very technical um
you know counterparts or business
partners more confidence in like the
analytics we were showing or the metrics
or kpis that we were showing
um because a lot of the kpis we're
showing on these dashboards don't exist
in any one you know data warehouse we're
calculating on the fly in the server of
the shiny app so it's a way to be able
to sort of you know bridge the gap from
the detail to
the higher level data points that you're
communicating
it's really useful thank you javier
i i think that's come up quite a bit too
on um
like also with getting people on board
from excel to
think about learning r like giving
people that option to always have the
excel
version of something too
there were there's so many awesome
questions here um so i want to make sure
that we get to some that were on slido
as well and i know
toyan had to
jump i believe but i want to make sure
to ask this question
but elia toyan had asked
what strategies would you have for
someone on your team
to kind of combat combat imposter
syndrome
that is a really good question um
so i would say to combat imposter
syndrome
really is
i think it takes just more practice so
just more like fine-tuning your skills
um and
even just producing things maybe for
yourself maybe like your own projects
that can really just back up your
expertise um and then i also
um and
am really big on
um just learning how to
um
communicate and then even just
practicing like communicating like your
methods communicating your results
um so i think that the more that
someone shares what they've done what
they're doing that it helps them become
a bit more confident in their skills
and then also to
not you know put so much pressure on
yourself but to understand that
everyone's learning
um and even like people that have high
skills they're always learning there's
always something new to learn everyone's
not going to know everything
but to just be patient with yourself
but you know keep going keep learning
your skills and you will continue to get
better
you and i i realize that's something
that so many people
face even people that i think are like
the smartest people in the room
um
sorry i'm trying to scroll through from
earlier questions so there was one on
slido that was asked anonymously
when you were talking about tools that
you use
and it was what was the reason for
moving away from power bi
and then asking also do you use shiny
for visualizations
um so
i would say that the
the now that's a good question so i that
decision was something that was made
before my time um
and i think you know i don't know too
much about power bi someone can correct
me um but
to me it just sounds like it's something
that is um maybe a bit more easier to
use since we are able to utilize the
server
and people can connect live to data
sources on our server they can also like
download workbooks on our server um so i
feel like just maybe ease of use
and then with just building this this
enterprise of technologies uh probably
was um the vision for that um and then
the other question regarding our shiny
um i have used our shiny in the past um
to do some visualizations more so just
you know practicing on my own um just so
i can have an understanding of how to
use it
um but um i haven't used it in a you
know in a few years um and that i would
say is because most of our
visualizations have been in tableau now
thank you um
there was also a question from earlier
that was i think um
apologies if i'm pronouncing your name
incorrectly but if you want to jump in
you can ask that too
sure yeah it's uh my first name is brian
last name you got it okay
it's it's suey like chop
okay
i was like that's a hard one to
pronounce right yeah it is you'd be
surprised how many ways that can be
uh said um anyway um thanks for thanks
for having me uh it's been a really good
discussion
um one thing that that um a lot of upper
management that my company's concerned
with is
you know with so many people and so much
proliferation of some of these tools
like r and shiny
um
uh you know power bi things like that
power query um how do you manage
um the code um and what is that what
does that look like
um
you know how much reproducibility is
required i know probably in some of the
healthcare there's a lot of that in my
business there typically hasn't been
um and then also how do you govern um
new technologies because we always have
people that want to try the next shiny
bubble that comes along if it's not our
it's python or julia
or you know other technologies that
somebody you know some wants to try and
how do you how do you wrap your hands
around governing that
yeah so to answer your first question
um again with just expanding the
technologies that we're using um so we
will start using git lab um so that's
really exciting that we will be able to
create our repositories where we can um
share code across the agency um i think
with that that is going to be another um
heavy load of trying to get people to
actually use it and learn how to use it
and understand how to use it um but i
will say that there is a data cam course
on git so
we will plan to
um just let people know that it's out
there and probably make that um a
required course um to take
um so
um moving forward that is uh the goal
right now
um and then i i'm i know that on team
like smaller teams um as far as like
code sharing um inversion control um i'm
pretty sure that they like developed um
their own ways of doing things um but
again trying to
make this a lateral movement
um
that git lab will hopefully help us um
you know
we can implement this thing across the
agency um and then your second question
i'm sorry if you can repeat your second
question actually sure sure it was it
was about um
just new technologies or ideas that
people have to bring and introduce new
technologies in do you have a process
for doing that or is it case by case and
how do you manage that
i would say that it is case by case um
and
we are open
um to
mostly just look at well what are the
benefits so doing like a
cost benefit analysis
um
and then um maybe even piloting we have
done piloting in the past with certain
like analytics and platforms um to see
if this is something that we do want to
take on
um but yeah i definitely understand
where you're coming from that there is
always um this thing of like this is the
next new shiny
shiny thing that we want to use let's
let's try it out um but um i think
it's really just first we want to get
comfortable at least using these new
technologies that we're already
kind of standing up
um and then just taking it from there
really
i realized that a an hour just went by
so fast right now
um so
if some people have to drop right now i
just wanted to ask aaliyah if people
have follow-up questions what's the best
way to get in contact with you
yes so um you guys can feel free to
contact me on linkedin
um
i don't know if i should put it in the
chat or
yeah yeah you could put it in the chat
or we or robert can share it too okay
great um linkedin or even by email as
well and i'm happy to put my email in
the chat um
but yeah if if anyone is interested in
reaching out happy to discuss more
awesome and
there are a few more questions too but i
don't know if you have to run to another
meeting right now
so just let us know
i do have to hop off
um
but i'm happy to join another week
if i can be the the leader again but
yeah but if anyone has any follow-up
questions please feel free to like reach
out
um yeah
awesome thank you so much for joining in
and sharing your insights with us and
thank you to everyone for all the
questions too i feel like this is one of
the like
i
think the most questions of any session
so far so apologies for not getting to
some of them um
we are working on
creating like a data science hangout hub
where we'll be able to share like all
the resources and video snippets and
everything for everybody too
some more to come on that in january
but just want to say thank you all so
much for kicking this off with us this
year as well
so i know we just started this in
july or so
so thank you all
for everyone joining today have a great
rest of the day everyone
you